everyone today I'll be talking about
deterministic docker images with Bill
microservices as you can tell by the
name of the talk first some fun facts my
name is john san miguel i also go by jsm
I'm on jsm on the slack strange loop
slack if you want to find me after or
talk to me currently working at samsara
and as part of that I'm working on
observability right now part of our core
infrastructure team and also I have a
cat I'd have like no social media
presence at all but my cat does have an
Instagram so if you want to follow my
cat go for it cool so first let's talk
about why this is even like valuable so
in our in our case what we wanted to do
was we want to make deploys as fast as
possible I'd say I'm sorry and there's a
few times there's a few reasons why we
Michael might want to do that there is
um some winds around developer velocity
being able to iterate on features as
quickly as possible and push things out
there's also a bunch of changes that
sometimes need to wait for other changes
to get deployed first before we can
actually roll them out and there's also
bug resolution time for customers just
if you find a bug and fix it it would be
great if we can get it out as quickly as
possible and so both of these things
kind of lead to happy engineers and
happy customers so before I get into it
I just want to talk a little bit about
what we do at samsara um just to get a
better idea of what we're what this is
for so we have a bunch of devices that
gather a bunch of data from a bunch of
various things trucks machinery
industrial plant applications and then
send that to our devices and send that
to our cloud platform where we do a
bunch of different things around like
analytics and stuff for those companies
I like to think of it I was like
basically data dog for the real world
metrics that you might find and so to do
this what we do for our stack is we have
a react react front ends for our mobile
and our website and those talk to our
servers via graph QL
which in turn talked to a bunch of micro
services via G RPC which are all built
in going and we push this all out with
build kite terraform onto ECS and
finally on docker containers and when I
say we use golang at samsara we use
going a lot we use it for services we
use it for our our deploy orchestration
we use it for generating terraform files
we use it for managing our teams and
like configuring our teams via going
struck so everything in our back-end is
go which has actually been pretty great
because everyone knows how to work in
that kind of codebase and it like makes
working and integrating with different
parts of our platform really easy and
when I say we have going micro services
we have a lot of those to go actually we
actually have more micro services and
then engineers right now and I know you
might be thinking our micro service is
really that good I'm not gonna go into
that kind of argument I belong thoughts
if you want to ask me about them but we
can talk about that another time
so instead here's some pictures of my
cat
anyways cool so before we dive into the
kind of pieces let's talk about what
determinism means in this context so
what we're talking about here is byte
for byte determinism where you compile
and package the same exact code and that
should lead to the same exact docker
digest and so the way this helps is for
a few things that strips out time from
having to move these darker layers
across the network from our CI systems
for different servers to new servers
that come up as we auto-scale it also
really helps when we for enabling no op
deploys for unchanged micro services
which saves a lot on basically like
shutdown and startup time of these
services and also there's less downtime
on singleton services that we have where
we can only run one
there's prevent the prevents a lot of
initialization outages like if you have
to talk to ec2 Matt a data service or
talk to a config system or talk to your
secret system once that gets started
then the services won't have to deal
with those kind of issues if you don't
have to take them down for no reason and
so overall you get a lot of speed and
reliability gains from doing this
cool so I want to also want to talk
about what deploying a service looks
like at samsara so basically we compile
go binary we build it into a docker
image and then we ship it to ECS so to
get there I'll be talking about three
different sections for this talk I'll be
talking about how to make go line
compilers deterministic I'll be talking
about how to make docker builds
deterministic and also how to reduce
large dependency graphs and I'll be
using reproducible and deterministic
kind of interchangeably in this talk so
they kind of essentially will mean the
same thing for what I'm talking about
here so the first thing like I said is a
building deterministic going binaries
that's the first thing that we need to
do to get anywhere and there are some
issues with this with going right now
going includes paths of standard
packages used in go route there's it
includes passive libraries using go
paths if you see go for importing
various see dependencies then the host
linker generally includes passive linked
objects into the binary as well and it
also includes an arbitrary build ID and
these binaries which make going right
now not deterministic even though it
doesn't tend to be and there's some
different strategies you can use to
tackle these different issues for the
going paths there's a few kind of very
vague or not well documented things that
you can do one of which is you there's
this go route final environment variable
where you can change the go with path
prefix to a static value there's also a
trim path flag that they added and I
think 1.9 or 10 that allow stripping
paths of libraries in the go path down
to just the import name we don't
actually do either of these at samsara
on what we do instead is we compile all
of our services inside of these kind of
identical build containers that we use
in our CA and CD pipelines so that kind
of strips out these issues for us and
there's also this a host linker thing
where we there's different linkers that
you can use there's a host linker
there's a you can use a go lines
internal linker and if you use going to
internal linker then it
doesn't include the pass of the linked
objects in the binary and also does not
include that build ID and so we use this
flag at samsara with some white listed
services that just don't work with the
internal linker for various reasons and
this gets us most of the way to going
determinism and what I want to talk
about next is kind of just to dive into
like some stuff that has happened with
this so going in 1.7 introduced a new
compiler back-end based on static single
assignment form where basically this is
a design principle of compilers where if
you represent a program in this form
then the it makes a lot of optimizations
it enables some optimizations that can't
exist without it and also makes a lot of
other optimizations a lot better and so
there's a lots of some big improvements
in the compiler and performance speed of
packaged binaries and this also
introduced a regression at some point
where essentially what would happen is
that by using this SSA divide
instructions within within the binary
rule requires values and specific
registers and so if you have two
subsequent divide instructions then the
result of those need to be moved
somewhere else before the second as
issued and so they made a fix to this at
some point or basically and this was
introduced in 1.8 beta where when
allocating registers before kicking out
the existing value they would copy it to
a spare register if there is one and so
as part of this kind of a performance
improvement they added this code and
I'll let you guys take a look at this
for a little bit and see if any anyone
who might be a compiler expert can see
what's wrong with this code essentially
what's happening here is that they have
this list of register copies and they're
going through them and finding if
they're they were never used and then if
they will if they weren't used then they
would basically free that register copy
and this was the code in case anyone
thought of something similar this is the
code that fixed that specific
determinism issue so what's happening
here is essentially that if you delete a
register copy that is unused that
actually might potentially leave another
register whose only use is pointing to
that other register that you just
deleted and so what you might end up
with if you just do this once is another
unused register after you do this clean
up and so what this what they added here
is basically a loop where they just keep
doing this until it gets to this if no
progress break and this progress thing
only happens if they actually execute
that inner block and so they'll
basically just keep going through all
the registered copies until they get to
a point where they happen to leave than
anything
and so this fixed the determinism issue
and 1.8 and so to kind of just let
highlight that a little bit more so you
have a registered copy pointing to
another register copy point to another
register copy you run the script it
deletes one but now you have another one
that's pointing to nothing and then so
what they did is they just kept doing
this where you would do this again and
again does anyone else have does anyone
have an idea what happens when they do
this for the last time you might be
thinking nothing but it's actually
another picture of my cat in a box but
yeah so eventually they get to this
point where they get rid of all these
unused register copies and that's how
they fix that determinism bug and go
cool so before I move on to the next
part about how to make docker build
deterministic I'm just gonna give you
guys old break play picture play video
of my cat
[Music]
alright now we've all been able to
refresh our minds let's talk about
deterministic dr. builds so the next
thing we want to do as part of this is
well make our dogger build for our going
but a binary is deterministic and so you
might be thinking some of you who are
more familiar with docker that doesn't
this kind of already work doesn't this
already happen if you have dot when you
were in docker builds you can they can
use a cache where basically if you run
docker build with the same exact input
it'll use the existing cache and use
existing layers instead of having to
build them again but what happens with
pipeline deploys with this kind of
caching mechanism so if you look at kind
of deploying a service there's a build
step there's a deploy step when you want
to build that service again you do it
again build deploy build deploy so let's
talk about doing this in a specific case
where you have the first build is
basically v1 of the service and then the
second one is v2 and 3rd build actually
got triggered but it's the same exact
service in the code hasn't changed this
will work just fine using cache if you
do this in this kind of like single
pipeline kind of way but if you move to
this kind of pipelines thing we did this
to basically make our deploys happen as
quickly as possible we decided we did
not need to wait for the previous
version to deploy before releasing the
next or before starting to build the
next version and so the issue here that
you might see is that we have this V to
deploy happening but it hasn't finished
and so we can't actually use the cash
from that deploy because it actually
hasn't been hasn't finished deploying it
and so what happens here is that even
though there's a v2 that the third
deploy is the exact same version as the
second deploy I won't be able to use a
cache and thus will have to go through
the whole build itself without using a
cache and that will end up with a
different docker digest and the reason
for that if we dive into that a little
bit more
is that there are some issues with
docker reproducibility they never really
kind of intended for docker to be
completely deterministic run commands
are just non-deterministic by nature if
you're doing an app to get for some
packages the repository could have
changed the actual code that you're
actually apt-get installing and so you
cannot actually rely on run to be
deterministic at all the file system
digest also includes M times and so when
it makes the the layer hash it'll take
into account that and also it also
includes a random a random hex string as
identifier and not just the
cryptographic hash of the layer content
and so to actually get around this
there's a few things that you can do one
don't use run instead of using run you
can like basically build a base image
that you you build at like set intervals
or manually for any dependencies that
need to be installed you need to reset N
times across the file system and you
have to manually construct the docker
layer with their own identifier and this
is basically kind of just rewriting
docker with some stuff with some with
some changes and so I started going off
on this route and I realized that
there's actually something that does all
this for you
it's called Basel built by Google and so
using Basel they they do all that stuff
for you in fuse Basel you comes out with
deterministic docker image where the
exact where the docker digests is
exactly the same if you give it the
exact same input so we use it's I'm
sorry this is just some snippet of some
of our configuration scripts like I said
we use go for everything and so we
actually generate these via go but the
interest the thing to point out here is
we use this base image called dis
realists which is a Debian based
bare-bones distro that from whoa
from Google and so these images are
basically like really stripped down they
don't contain a shell they don't contain
a package manager they only really
contain your application and its runtime
dependencies this makes it so you don't
go you don't actually need dependencies
for the most part because they're
compiled in the binary
and so this works pretty well with go
and then but also like me fixes a lot of
security problems and that you don't
have a shell so people can't execute
stuff in your in your container you
don't have a package manager so you
could people you don't have to worry
about like checking shah's and stuff and
so it makes it also has a bunch of the
stuff that you actually need to run
going images started going binaries and
so it works pretty well for going they
also have destroyed images for various
other languages like I think they have
one for Python and Java so you could
take a look at their their images for
using basil of this another thing I like
to do is I like to tell potential
candidates at X hey I'm sorry that we've
been using docker 50 years it's just not
true because doctors only been around
for like 10 years or so but when I
talked about earlier about how you have
to reset the end times in the file
system if you do that then you do with
docker images it prints out all of your
images and it says those built 49 years
ago so that's kind of nifty cool so the
last thing that I want to be talking
about here is basically how you can
minimize your dependency chains so
determinism doesn't actually help with
golang if your code changes like way too
frequently and this could happen because
[Music]
actually before that I want to talk
about what I talked about before so just
kind of coding myself so compelling and
packaging the same code will end up with
the same docker digest I want to kind of
clarify what packaging what the same
code means and the in the world of go
and so if you look at go they have a and
you look at the internal linker they
have a dead code remover but we use
golang 1.1 1.2 Levin right now and 1.11
unused static functions are removed from
the binary but they can still actually
change the digest of the binary also if
reflect is used go on can't ignore
methods on structs going has a bunch
going has this reflection package where
you can base
we pull out a method on the struct by
name and so because of that you can't
actually determine whether or not a
method inside of a struct is actually
used if the program imports reflect or
specific methods of reflected and so if
you use reflect going the going deadhead
remover cannot actually strip out any
methods on your structs and by doing so
even if you don't use any of these
unused functions or you don't use any of
these methods in your code as long as
you use something else in that package
the binary will the binary output will
include information around that package
and so essentially when we're talking
about the code being the same and golang
we're really talking about the package
being the same and so if any part of the
package or its imports changes than the
binary changes this is mostly true and
it's it's a pretty good assumption to
make although it might not be true in
all cases and so based off of this kind
of information you can to make any you
can't make any assumptions about this
your service only includes this function
all you've changes that one function and
your and your program and so sorry if
another function and you're in your
program in your package has changed even
if you don't actually use that function
your binary will still change so that
kind of a makes things a little bit more
difficult because now you have a bunch
of code that you might not even be
looking at or using and those change and
that affects your by affects your binary
and so if you another way to kind of
think about it that I like to use as a
metaphor is for anyone who's read or
watched Enders game they have this
weapon called the little doctor and
essentially what it does is shoots this
giant laser beam and but it only works
if the actual things that it's targeting
are close enough together where it can
cause a chain explosion slash reaction
and so I want you to think of this laser
as your build or CI system and I want
you to think of all those alien ships as
their micro-services and what you don't
want is for your micro services to
explode into a fiery death
and so kind of playing off this metaphor
what you need to do for your services is
you need to keep them far enough apart
where they're not too dependent on any
shared code where it would cause a chain
reaction of changing one thing actually
propagates changes to all of your other
micro services and then even if you're
using determinism like you change one
small helper library and then everything
just starts deploying anyways so there's
a that that was probably the hardest
challenge out of this whole of this
whole project was to make this better
and so we wrote two tools to help with
this there's one called depth stat which
is for a dependency analysis and there's
one called import checker which
disallows and certain imports with
certain rules and I'm currently working
on open sourcing these I'll give you
guys a link to the base repo that is
currently empty but will be pushed there
once it's ready and so I want to talk a
little bit about what this does and how
it works basically it builds a graph of
a all of your services and what they
import and all of their direct and ports
all their child imports and after
building this graph there's a lot of
cool and nifty things that you can do
with that so one of the commands in
depth stat is counts so I run this
command and I can actually see number of
services that are being that are using a
particular package and so in this case
this is a sorted by the least frequently
important we have a bunch of packages
that are only being imported by one
service but we also have a bunch of
packages are being imported by a bunch
of services and if you find a package
that you see that's being imported by
all of your services with this tool you
can dig into that a little bit and you
can run the step set package command
which will you pass in the package and
it'll tell you all of these services
that are dependent on that particular
package in this case we're using it to
kind of look at this like imports of
this legacy system this is kind of one
of our you know everyone has legacy code
and lying around we have a few services
still using that and this is a tool to
help us identify which of those services
are still using that and this legacy
system also does dependency does not use
dependencies very well
for our services we use this thing
called FX 2d dependency injection which
allows us to add in dependencies like
our data dog client our our like log
client and a bunch of other like various
things we might want to inject into
runtime without actually having to call
imports at in the actual code layer and
so one of the things that I worked on
was also helping deprecated services
that use this legacy system we have over
like 200 services so now there's
probably around 20 left so to the pretty
good job there of getting that done
there's this other command and deb stat
which is probably the coolest one it's
called dep stat deploys and it walks
through all the commits and will
basically tell you this commit changed
this particular package which caused
these particular services to deploy and
you can kind of use this to kind of to
get a better idea of how bad your
dependencies are if you see a deploy and
it seemed to trigger all of your
services to change you can find the
commit and find what caused that
what package cause that propagating
deployment and the last thing I want to
talk about is this stuff set command
called Y which so you found that a
service that was deployed and you saw it
was deployed because of the change
inside of another package it's not easy
to walk the import tree to actually
understand why this package is being
imported by our service and so this
tells you about how this actual packages
is being imported so you can see here
that legacy system is imported by this
thing called stat server which is
imported by this thing called Copiah
service router and now it's imported by
this server by the service that we're
looking at so that's def stat and the
other tool I talked about was import
checker so imports are basically gives
you a way to define these rules on
different packages and you can say
essentially that I have this package and
no one can no one can import it and then
you can also provide a whitelist that
kind of overrides that and you can say
well these particular services can't
import it and this is good for basically
helping you
keep people from importing code that
you've identified should not be imported
by everyone cool so you have these tools
but there's also a bunch of code
patterns that you kind of have to do
that you can't that it's hard to write
tooling for but basically you want to
break up the large packages you we have
a giant helpers package you might have
one too that has a bunch of various
helper functions in code so you want to
break that up into smaller packages you
also want to move commonly used configs
constants and types into their own sub
package and also you want to split
frequently change code from the more
static portions so say you have for
example a a configuration object that
lists like the names of your services
and how many of those you want to deploy
at the same time and you have a bunch of
other code that takes that and then like
will generate or control is you have
other code that it's like orchestration
tooling that will use that configuration
to do whatever you're doing the actual
orchestration code itself probably won't
change much like the way you're actually
taking this configuration and deploying
stuff the code itself probably won't
change much but if you're changing the
configuration a lot then that will cause
that particular package to change all
the time and so by splitting up
frequently changed code for the more
from the more static code then that
helps with this kind of dependency
chain-reaction thing and also you want
to vendor your dependencies properly
going has a vendor directory thing and
there's a bunch of various dependency or
package managers and go I think the
official one is now like Vigo but you
want to make sure that you're pulling
your dependencies on a static way either
checking them into vendor or pulling
them based off of a specific version or
hash so that way your vendor libraries
aren't causing a chain reaction of
binaries to change by like doing like
changing something that you might not
even use so it's good to kind of just
bend or vendor your packages and the
more deterministic way and this was kind
of the result of of what happened here
where essentially we this was
for this was after so what we're doing
here is we're basically building all of
our services in the end we're deploying
all of them and so this took about an
hour and a half and then in some cases
on in our previous deploy system and by
doing making this change we were able to
cut down build times by quite a bit and
so at some point we're pretty much
deploying like three times an hour and
when I say deploying I mean deploying
hundreds of different micro services at
the same time and so yeah it was a
pretty successful project and so the
last thing I just want to go over is a
summary of what I talked about here so
the first step to this was making our
going compiles deterministic the second
step was making a docker build
deterministic and then the third step
was reducing these large dependency
graphs that's the end of my talk I'm
gonna save the rest of the time for Q&A
but if you want to reach out to me
I'm github.com /j smj I might say I'm
sorry comm my cat's Instagram handle
again is prints dot of dot meow and that
repo that I told you about where I'll be
pushing the DEP stat code will be in
github comm / samsara HQ / DEP stat and
lastly I put in some things for let's
encrypt for they provided some notes
that they used as a reference for some
of the deterministic golang stuff and
also slides Carnivale comm for these
slide templates cool
any questions what's up
oh maybe I'll look into that yeah we're
still using go vendor I'm not sure if
like Vigo has actually been like is out
of beta and so we're kind of waiting for
that to get out of beta before we move
to that
sorry I'm not following a question
yeah I think I'm not sure how Vigo works
like right now they probably like figure
out which packages you're importing
based off of looking at stuff and you
might like it might only reference likes
it might pull things based off of like
thus function signatures and package
signatures and you might need to like
actually like pin it to a specific
version if you needed to do that yeah
yeah I think there's so Basel also
includes has its own like go rules to
like build go binaries and then also
they I think they have some dependency
management that they can do themselves
as well so I think there might be other
tools for this as well
I am building sorry no no I'm not
building go binaries with basil
does that IV I've used it before does it
kind of solve the similar like similar
problems okay take a look at that - cool
I need anything else
sweet well that's the end of my talk and
I'll stick around for any questions that
anyone might have probably over here so
come find me
also I want to give a shout out to
samsara for sponsoring this event as
well we have a table on the first floor
downstairs so I'll also be hanging out
there as well if you want to come chat
with some of us also Joey right there
it's also at samsara if you want to talk
to her about mobile stuff cool thanks